he could have easily been the MVP of
Super Bowl 50 for as he's the first
player in Super Bowl history with over a
hundred rushing yards a rushing
touchdown and one receiving touchdown in
the game and he's now tied for most
total touchdowns in the players first
six playoff games all-time the other
person who he's tied with is a Pro
Football Hall of Famer also from his
sandy a native San Diego Terrell Davis
he's Damien Williams how are you Damien
I am fine what was that parade like it
sounds like it and I appreciate you
using the final Parsons of your vocal
cords to call it to this show right now
but what was the craziest thing you saw
from atop one of those buses fan base
that we had just to see you know
everybody out there on top of roofs
Thompson it was just crazy like it was
mr. Shafer and so when you you know saw
green grass in front of you in the
fourth quarter what was going through
your mind Damien Williams kind of a
little bit you know one side you know
game I balanced it I was on my way there
why this game what did it mean for you
what did it mean for you that you did it
in Miami of all places
that's a lot you know just because you
know I said my first four years there
you know they brought me in creative you
know they believed in me fans believe in
it and anything being back you know for
that we just I had a lot of you know
Miami Dolphins fans you know still some
you know we love you still you know go
get it go get it for us there played it
you know it just felt great being back
were you in though did you have the
Miami locker room through the honking so
knows and you know the locked room and
we also practice after practice facility
you know all good for the holy if I had
told you when you suffered that shoulder
injury in Miami if I'd come up to you
and I said to you hey don't worry I know
you might be down right now but you're
gonna come back in this stadium with the
Kansas City Chiefs and score touchdown
and when Super Bowl 54 for them what I
would have you said to me it's been just
a wild ride for Damian Williams who's
here on the Rich Eisen show why did you
seek out Raheem most hurt after the game
Damian that's my friend beyond
everything tonight you know the game we
just wide by celebrating you know
everything is going on and I've seen
them running off not do not spoke to him
before the game you know he makes us do
medicine I've told him like you know I
don't care if you guys were in our way
you know I still want to speak to you
regardless of mixing ripeness the only
way you know officer you know I
understand you know but emotions and
everything I played on that game you
know they work and we thought they were
win so I know you know he really felt
bad you know about how the game checks
out but you know I just have you chased
me down they know this you know you know
be there for them because you know these
are some like I said real friends before
unit well I mean it's it's it's pretty
wild though that here's your moment you
you've just won the Super Bowl your
teammates are all out there and that you
took a moment to seek out you know a
member of the opposition but somebody
that obviously knows what it's like to
be an undrafted free agent to go through
an entire draft process not hearing your
name
and then make your name for yourself I
just found that fascinating that you
said you know I'm gonna take the time to
do that
something amazing so you guys Swamp
jerseys did you see what he posted that
he's willing to give it back to you
Damon
yeah let him actually talk to you know
tied to that and you know he told me
that he's gonna give it back and all
that so I was excited you know I'd like
to say you know to me a bit Maddie you
know baby said you know and I want to
get it back and you know what I'm not
give us back then I'll say judicial one
is I also enjoyed this one it's gonna
look good okay so you're gonna send his
back right yes it is back with the
different Jersey okay and who's picking
it up was tracking number is everybody
using call him a survivor so that's
really cool man
what does this mean for your for Andy
Reid Damien when you showed up obviously
a couple years ago and there was Kareem
hunt and then they turned to you in a
more significant way when hunt was
released what did we do for you and what
do you think this means for him that you
were able to do this on his behalf as
well
you know you know money so you know my
background and being a great package
back you know and then you know and
coming out here and having it in like
you do with this core i7 movie Damon and
I'll go you know merely had a bump in it
to get in your own he's proud of me and
now what for you I mean you've you've
done something that no undrafted free
age
is done which has scores six touchdowns
in a single postseason you've tied
Terrell Davis and you know from San
Diego what that means in terms of first
six career playoff games having 11
touchdowns ewtodd TD on that what's next
for you Damien right now it's on the
moment and I'm wait a minute
but you know suing them after you know
put this behind me and get ready for
next year come back bigger better
stronger you know I got not set up I'll
send a golden and I want to reach it
faster and well what's your favorite
mahomes story Damien whether it was the
first time you met him or something in a
huddle or anything that's happened off
the field I asked you for your favorite
Patrick mahomes story and it would be
what Damien going down the field put
your own jong-kul yards no you have a
basketball hoop locker room and you have
every good quarterback who's young
now he wants to be involved in oh god no
we playing you're aggressive and just
you know just fooling around you know
you don't want your MVP quarterback in
there you know takes me down the lane
and laying the ball you got to shoot the
ball you said he'll I don't you know you
got to sit out we didn't know he's a kid
he's having fun like everybody in the
market so what do you mean when he tells
you to go down the field close your eyes
and hold your hands he's he's thrown a
pass to you a ball on there he's laid it
once to rush straight down his line
don't know hold your hands out and I
would usage in the hands of the ball and
does he do it yeah
yeah we've done it before and my god
alright you caught it didn't go on your
grill or anything like that it's just
that all right Damien well congrats on
having a great Super Bowl are you gonna
go to Disney World anyway I mean you're
damn near got there yourself alright
well we'll try and make that happen we
know some people in the world of Disney
that's for darn sure
congratulations on that on the
incredible run and the parade and on
everything that's gone on in your life
it's a life-changing moment and if
you're in Los Angeles Damien I'd love to
have you right here on the show let's
look forward to it thanks for the call
thank you you got that Damien Williams
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under wreck TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app